[Musique]
le petit chanteur pleurait plus chantait
tout
dégoûté sa petite Nini
parti pauvre petit ça vaêtre quoi ça
[Musique]
dans les journaux
g il bous tous ces gens la pauvre
chanteur pauvre
chanteur à la télé c'est sûr pour cacher
sa
blessure sur sa figure il y a des tonnes
de peinture c'est
[Musique]
dur si tu es chanteur que tu pleleur on
dit mon dieu quel cœur bravo le
décorateur
oui mais si tu es tourneur PDG promoteur
ou le vieux
[Musique]
rémouleur ta Nini est
parti tu es tout seul dans ton lit tout
le monde s'en fout tu m'as
compris pas moyen ça c'est sû pour
cacher ta
blessure te sur la figure des connes de
peinture c'est dur dur
dur les n quand c'est parti c'est pleurs
douleur hystérie Wagner la
valkyriie si tu le PAP encore tu pris le
président le safari mais nous il y a que
le
[Musique]
kanti tu es pas vraiment
chanteur tues pasê en couleur pour ton
cœur trouve ton
cœur il y a pas ton électroue carbure
dans les
journaux ton chagrin sur le dos tu es un
escargot qui dit beauo
[Musique]
beauo le petit chanteur pleurit plus
chanté tout
dégoûter sa petite n par Pau petit
ça va AC toi ça vie c'est chanteurs que
tu pleures on dit mon dieu quel cœur
bravo le décorateur
oui mais si es t PDG promoteur
le
[Musique]
vieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]